I'm originally from Aiken South Carolina
but I am now a general surgeon in
Anniston Alabama halfway between Atlanta
and Birmingham so patient comes in we go
through the history and physical process
come up with the diagnosis and let's say
they have to have their gallbladder out
I go through my small risk and benefits
conversation which is usually the same
conversation each time then I start
playing the video while I leave the room
the nurse is outside getting all of the
paperwork ready to schedule a surgery
and the gallbladder video is about three
minutes which is about the exact amount
of time that it takes for the nursing it
ready so what she does in that case is
comes back into the room they finished
the video and the nurse again will ask
them if they have any questions the nice
thing about the animation is that it's
very well put together it answers pretty
much 90% of the questions that most
patients have about surgery when you add
on the ability to have video associated
with that information it not only allows
a patient to kind of get a better
conception of what's going on but I
think that they become a little more
comfortable like okay he told me this
the video says this it's almost like
having a second doctor come in and tell
them that something is going on and
that's what they're going to have done
so they become extremely comfortable
when patients come in and for one reason
the nurse doesn't put the video on or I
forget to put the video on we've noticed
that those are the patients that
typically call back with questions or in
some instances they have questions right
before they undergo the procedure so
when the videos are playing we almost
have no questions no follow-up questions
the basses are comfortable they're
regular surgery and the surgical process
will start to finish is smooth in the
patient step
you